[Music]
hey guys so how to pin this routine
going are you still as excited and
motivated as when you first started or
are you starting to hear yourself saying
I don't feel like exercising I don't
have time to exercise let me just skip
my workout for today
let me just indulge and be good again
tomorrow let me tell you this I don't
always feel like exercising and I don't
always enjoy my training especially when
it is really tough but that doesn't mean
I choose to continue to flit in of skip
my workout session just because I don't
feel like it at that moment so I want to
share with you how I keep myself
motivated and discipline even when I was
on vacation to Australia if you need a
little bit of inspiration and motivation
to get up and train be sure to watch
this video through so my first tip is to
track your meals and fitness progress
I've said in my previous video about
using the lights on a bag to help me
track all my meals and also activities
if you haven't started tracking your
fitness progress be sure to download the
lifetime app by clicking on the link in
my description box below I knew that I
had a cover shoot once I'm back and I
wanted to look my best so I really had
to be aware of what I eat but at the
same time I wanted to be able to enjoy
all the delicious foods while on holiday
during my travels I took pictures of all
my meals and roughly listed down what
and how much I ate using the app I
became more aware of my eating habits
and my husband in our vegetables are all
my milk too heavy and I indulge in too
often and am i drinking enough water
throughout the day if I noticed that I
wasn't consuming enough vegetables for
lunch then I would choose a meal with
more vegetables during dinner and if I
had a huge breakfast or lunch I would in
to go for something lighter for dinner
I would also check my activities if I
wasn't walking enough instead of taking
the chair back to the hood
I would encourage my friend to walk for
20 to 30 minutes back to the hotel
eventually she started enjoying the
challenge and wanted to hit our daily
goal of at least 12,000 steps when you
start tracking what you eat and how
active you are you start to realize what
and how much you actually eat you're
more likely to make healthier choices
you'd want to be more active you would
also learn to enjoy your favorite treats
in moderation you will receive immediate
feedback on your progress you'll know
immediately how your choices will
contribute or detract from your fitness
goals and as a result your finis goals
become more attainable the next step is
to set a specific goal don't just say I
want to lose 20 kilos in 6 months I can
tell you that 90% of people who set a
weight goal never achieve it you got to
add more fun to it challenge yourself
and sign up for a 10k run and shrink -
it's that or set a goal of taking your
family for a hiking trip you might have
a wedding goal my goal this time was to
feel and look my best
ready for my photo shoot so on days when
I wasn't feeling motivated especially
when I was on vacation I spoke to myself
about how good and confident I will feel
on the day of my shoot that really kept
me going and I maintained my discipline
throughout the entire month despite my
crazy schedule and no matter where I was
so whatever your goal is be specific as
a little bit of challenge to it make it
fun write it down
and remind yourself daily next you got
to plan ahead while I was traveling I
didn't just decide there and then that
do you know what I'm going to work out I
planned it way before my trip I
consciously booked a hotel that offers
basic gym and pool facilities and
because I was traveling with another
friend it wasn't fair for me to describe
our plan just because Johanna wanted to
work out so I had to make the effort to
get up way earlier before she did and
hit the gym by 7:00 in the morning
of course I secretly wanted to just
lighten
that and do nothing so I had a decision
whether to get up workout and feel good
for the rest of my day or choose the
right in for one extra hour feel crappy
regretful and just complain and complain
what I'm trying to say is that you don't
just stumble upon success you're not
going to achieve results if you just
think and wish upon it you have to be
ready to invest in yourself plan ahead
and stay discipline and do it even when
you don't feel like doing it every time
you do something that you know is good
for you even when you don't feel like it
you're building self-discipline I like
to think of this we all must suffer from
one or two pins the pin of discipline or
the pain of regret what's your choice
commit publicly I've always encouraged
you to share your fitness progress with
me
when you commit your goals publicly it
makes me feel more accountable and in a
way you have set up a challenge to
succeed in order to prove yourself and
this can be a huge motivator one of my
favorite features on the lifestyle app
is being able to connect with your
friends to challenge and motivate each
other your friends will be able to see
all your moves and exercises you can
even copy each other's meals and
exercises to stay motivated together so
on days when you're slacking off your
friends will be able to give you a good
reminder so invite your friends on the
lifetime app and start motivating each
other don't be too hard on yourself but
don't find excuses either you have a
clear goal you're ready to commit and
give your 100% but hey nothing ever goes
according to plan you would definitely
be faced with challenges and you may
even fall back into your old habits you
might need several workout sessions over
it and cry about it how you choose to
tackle those situations would define the
outcome you can either continue to
self-pity or learn to train yourself to
look at every fat bag as an opportunity
to strengthen your willpower just
character and learn from your mistakes
yourself how can I improve on that what
can I do in order not to fall back into
my same old habits it is not an excuse
for you to walk away and just give up
remember that Fitness is not a
destination it is a journey and it is a
process fitness isn't something you
start and stop three months later
because you have achieved your fitness
goal it is a lifestyle you continues to
stay active and eat well because if you
want to be in your best state both
mentally and also physically so the
lifetime app has been a huge part of my
fitness journey I would encourage you to
try it out and download this app for
free by clicking on the link in my
description box below I believe that
this can be your guide and also a
motivator so be sure to like this video
share this video with your friends who
might feel demotivated and you can also
review these tips when you feel like
you're falling off track be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel for more
workout videos recipes and also fitness
tips other back
[Music]
[Music]